all right hey this is Pete peppers and
this is a candy crush soda saga bubble
gum tutorial bubble gum was a new game
mode or level type that came out a while
ago and it's similar to chocolate but a
little bit different so we're gonna play
some and talk about how it works all
right so we see hmm
we have bubble gum on the board the goal
is to clear it out and you can see here
that there's two different thicknesses
there's a single thickness here that the
candy just sits on top of and you can
move these candies around and things and
then you have this one where the candy
is actually wrapped up inside of it so
the regular single layer like this you
can make a match over it and it
disappears same here
so now this one like I said it's double
its trapped inside so we can still match
but you'll see what happens whenever you
match it freeze that piece but there's
still a layer left behind so it's pretty
simple like that hmm like I said it is
similar to chocolate in that it grows
I'm gonna have to make a little space so
if I make a match that doesn't hit the
hit public um you'd see that it'll grow
to another one and it'll grow around for
a period of time and then it'll uh it'll
start to cover the candies as well so as
far as tips for bubblegum you want to
set things up to take out the double
layers and you also want to try to keep
just like you do with chocolate you want
to keep some pressure on it so that it
doesn't grow you know all over the board
so here we want to make a fish and you
know every like sort of like every time
you do something that lets it grow then
you probably want to try to rein it back
in and this is a really easy bubble gum
level it's the first one but they get
pretty complicated trust me on that one
so here you know special candies you can
see what they do they take one layer off
so I just fired it across it free the
ones that were trapped in Double A or
left a layer behind and remove the
single iron out so that is the that's
the basic gist of it
we can um I'm gonna pause it and find a
more difficult water in their world rod
so I loaded up a yeah this is level 172
I think and it's a little bit more
complicated but here you can see there's
no candy strapped in it yet so obviously
you're gonna want to work your way down
and they fall right on top
and you know a color bomb pose a strike
we'll do the same thing it'll do the
chocolate it'll take out the Bubblegum
wherever it goes and that's how it works
oh I don't want to make this a really
long video because it's you know it's
fairly straightforward how it works just
keep in mind that you you know whenever
you're playing bubblegum levels that you
want to keep it from spreading too fast
and that you want to get those double
layers down as fast as you can so that
you can use the candies that are inside
and there's some pretty hard ones
there's some that are matched that are
mixed with honey as well so you have to
think a little bit about how to you know
battle both of those things but for the
most part you should be able to figure
it out and read our tips and the guide
and that will explain it a little bit
better if you have any questions leave a
comment like the video please and
subscribe to our channel so you can get
more updates on videos like this and
have a good one talk to you soon